des températures proches des 10 degrés
des blattes jusque dans les biberons dry
du matériel défectueux comme ce
lave-linge ou ce matelas voici ce
constat alarmant dressé par des salariés
de cette crèche dijonnaise elles
témoignent à visage couvert quand je
couche des enfants les on les laisse à
un petit pas brillé malgré ça il ya un
enfant comme keira peine deux ans qui
m'a dit est froid et froid je trouve que
c'est inadmissible quand on les change
il se tendent ils sont classés c'est
intolérable on ne se sent pas
professionnel dans nos pratiques en ce
sens complice de cette maltraitance
parce que c'est le cas
les devant la crèche fermée ce matin les
salariés affiche et chantent leurs
revendications
hier plus de matériel les parents eux
sont en colère ça me serre le coeur en
fête ça devrait être
propre saaq devrait être optimales pour
nos enfants pour que ça devienne comme
dans la com on voit dans les ehpad en ce
moment donc je comprends tout à fait à
leur mouvement de grève derrière une
entreprise ya la mairie et je comprends
pas qu'on puisse en arriver dans des
situations comme celle-ci je me demande
où est people and baby surtout fin
qu'est ce qu'ils font people and baby
c'est le groupe qui gère cette crèche
grâce à une délégation de service public
avec la mairie à la mairie justement on
assure ne pas avoir été tenu au courant
de la majorité des problèmes
délégataire de service public qui doit
rendre un service public donc quand le
service public n'est pas rendu et bien
la ville de dijon se sent responsable et
donc nous allons mettre en demeure le
concessionnaire actuelle pour qu'il
puisse remettre en état avant la fin de
la concession qui interviendra fin mai
2022 selon la mairie people and baby
devrait réaliser des interventions dans
la crèche dès demain matin l'entreprise
elle n'a pas donné suite à nos demandes
d'interview